so what does my next guest make of all
this the White House threat to sue Texas
Department of Public Safety Lieutenant
Chris olivades joins me now uh
Lieutenant thank you for being here so
just to put a fine point on it the
federal government's not doing its job
in closing the border so Texas at its
own expense is trying to fill in the
gaps and now the federal government is
suing Texas for doing what the federal
government should be doing it's it's
wild you know it is good morning David
of course you know you see that
hostility from our own federal
government trying to stop Texas and
protecting the sovereignty of our state
and essentially the country because our
state troopers are Texas National Guard
at the front lines right now while
border patrol agents are overwhelmed
processing The Surge of illegal
immigrants that are coming across the
border between ports of Entry but it is
quite shocking and this is something
that we've been dealing with for the
last three years when we're not only
dealing with the surge of illegal
immigration at the Border in Texas and
also having to go after and combat
criminal activity criminal organization
for smuggling drug smuggling but our own
federal government trying to stop us
when we're trying to stem that surge of
illegal immigration because they failed
to do it in the last three years you
just you just put up the numbers earlier
in your show um those numbers are quite
shocking that's only the first three
months of this fiscal year and yet
nothing still has not been done as far
as any significant change from the
federal government to stop this surge of
illegal immigration the only thing right
now that's inhumane that's causing harm
to these illegal immigrants that are
coming across our borders is the federal
government's failed border policies and
the state of Texas we're going to
continue stepping in David is doing as
much as we can and of course this was
anticipated we expected there was going
to be some type of lawsuit just like
with everything else we've done from day
one U from the Marine barrier that we
placed into the river the infrastructure
building our own border wall all the
different infrastructures we have put in
place at the expense of Texas taxpayers
uh we we did anticipate there was going
to be some type of push back from our
own federal government by the way
there's the other threat of of people
coming in the gut so-called gatways we
don't know anything about it we we just
explained that in the northern border uh
we caught an Iranian who was associated
with terrorists uh that could be
happening in a Southern border as well
have you seen any evidence of
that well well there has David there has
been for the last three years and that's
why I've always said that threats
already here the threat's been here when
you look at the amount of Goda ways over
1.7 million in the last three years
which I you know expect the numbers much
higher because the fact that we don't
know exactly that's just the based off
an estimation based off cameras and
sensors that was the whole purpose of
having this this law into place in Texas
was so that Texas law enforcement could
focus on those single adults those male
those single females that are coming
across between ports of Entry um to
actually arrest them for making un awful
unlawful ENT entry into the state of
Texas that way it'll free up it'll
alleviate some of those Federal
resources that way border patrol agents
can focus on those Goda ways focus on
those areas where there's
vulnerabilities along the border but yet
it seems like our own federal government
doesn't want us to to actually take any
action they want us to continue to you
know just turn a blind eye and continue
to let what's happening along the border
now we know the cost in terms of human
lives of all the fentanyl that's been
coming in a 100,000 Americans have died
as a result of the fentanyl coming in
across the border and of course a lot of
cities All Over America are facing costs
that they can't afford they're going
broke trying to pay for the migrants in
their in their place but there are also
deaths of migrants themselves who were
lured across this open border uh as far
as last I heard there were about a
thousand migrants who've died since Joe
Biden came into office right you know
that's a great Point daveid that's one
thing I think that we don't talk about
too much right we talk about the surge
of people coming across and the threats
and the National Security threats but
also the fact that this federal
government has allowed the highest
number of illegal immigrant deaths at
our Southern border and that's why when
you show that video of the press
secretary talking about that the
governor of Texas governor Abbott his
policy his new law is inhumane is going
to cause harm well it's it's really you
know it's re quite shocking toar hear
that when you see the fact that they
have allowed because of their border
policy the highest number of illegal
immigrant deaths that have taken place
along the border yet they still have not
put nothing in place to prevent that
unaccompanied children as well David and
of course you mentioned the fentanyl we
continue to see a mass production of
fentanyl that's coming across our bord
killing thousands of Americans every
single day and yet nothing's being done
to support these families well
Lieutenant as as you well know 2024 is
an election year it it may well make it
incumbent upon this Administration to
tighten up the Border a bit I certainly
for your sake I hope so Lieutenant Chris
olivades thank you so much for being
here again Lieutenant appreciate it hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now